and that is why gil carrillo real
gokaria wants to be
your sheriff if you're out there in the
united states and you'd like a week with
gil
he'll be the sheriff of your of your
county
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere
what's his name george george lopez
oh my god omg omg hi
oh my god
have you feeling overwhelmed lately uh
you're not alone start feeling better
with a single
message talkspace.online therapy matches
you with a licensed therapist
from the comfort of your device get 100
off your first month with oh my god hi
capital at talkspace.com
well full disclosure i ate a couple of
gummies on the way over here
because i haven't been out of the house
since
what i do tuesday hadn't been out of the
house and that was when you were here
and you know yeah that's where i was
here i hadn't gone out in a week
listen man i don't know what i've never
done heroin but
my room looks like a [ __ ] that
might have done heroin lived in there
like a
like food everywhere panca sonoto
is all over love rags
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] dude three
different [ __ ] shoes one shoe each
i'm like this must be what it's like to
do [ __ ] hair but i slept like a rock
man
reuben paul told me because i hadn't
worked in 14 months and all of a sudden
i worked two weekends yeah i'll take it
out of here think that's i don't think
that's
it uh well i know you had a fun surprise
you wanted to have me
i have a couple surprises so i know that
you're a dodger fan
who's what are some of your favorite
players oh
over the years don't say [ __ ] a stem
usually
leader of the stuntman when they hit a
home run
back when they uh beat oakland is he
with angels now uh
he's retired now he was he was with the
angels as a coach
and he's not doing anything right now
listen that dude you know how they you
know how they initiate you in gangs like
two dudes
stem like a whole group of guys right st
what they call
running the line or what do they call
that getting jumped in running the line
so you get like 10 or 20 guys on
opposite lines and then to get in
you have to run through the line while
they punch and kick you and
[ __ ] stab you you can get shot um
uh that's how they used to initiate
nikki hatcher he was always he was dirty
he always played he played hard
you could when i was trying to [ __ ]
already kick it in i lost my place
you could throw mickey hatchet through
the line put on his dodge uniform he
[ __ ] still get a base hit oh yeah
he was he was awesome when they beat
oakland when they weren't even supposed
to be on the same field as those guys
right
when they wanted up there i was out in
the field i was working on a murder
and andy ferrillo who used to not bud
really
bud furley used to work for the times
andy was his son and worked for the
examiner
at the time we had the herald examiner
at the time yeah so andy
used to see me he knew i was a season
ticket older i'd bump into him at the
baseball games well he called me up he
says hey gail what are you doing i said
what do you mean what i'm doing i just
come in from the field on a murder i'm
watching tv
it's the only game it's the only ticket
in town brother i'm watching the dodgers
and what do you think i said leader the
stuntman mickey hatcher my hero he hit
it out we won the game
i'm just i'm just all pumped up next day
headlines it was the only ticket in town
and then he quoted me in the paper and i
said oh that's awesome
season's over but that's awesome now
here's what you're going to do come
on next season i'm gonna go down you're
gonna take me down i want mickey
hatcher's autograph on my newspaper oh
yeah
yeah and so he got to get me down there
and i was i've been around stars such as
yourself
i've worked with stars you know on movie
sets and stuff like
but i mean i was down there with the
dodgers and it was
it was awesome there's nothing it was
nothing
i remember oral herscheiser when he
found out i was there and he said boy i
bet you
that must have been scary he must have
been nervous working that case
and i said no down here
i'm nervous i'm scared right yeah i
never had that it was that was it
i was sitting in the dugout with those
guys for a second while they were
warming up it was awesome
it it's it's like no other i mean i
guess
if people aren't dodger fans baseball
fans like you go
i don't know if the dodgers do what with
the for the fans they used to go
back in the days they would on sundays
they would sign
stickers that were like that were a
baseball
and it said dodgers at the bottom and
you could wait in line and then
the current dodge steve garvey or
somebody would sign the the ball sticker
and give it to you
and they were before the games they had
them doing [ __ ] i don't think you get
those guys to [ __ ] do it
sign your balls now that buck would be
like yeah
well the whole fat experience what about
uh uh the current current players
uh i i'm in there with cody ballinger
and jt
you know i those guys uh they're they're
leading right now
i'm just pulling forward since you're
not getting the [ __ ] hands
all right so i got you a gift because
this is uh
before you go on your own on your own
podcast
the sponsored by gordon's the fisher
gordon fisher
the bee squasher okay i know you were in
the military
this is my gift i know you love the
dodgers
it's signed by
[ __ ] who is it i can't even clayton
kershaw
wow a science there's that's clear
there's a real hero camo pattern that's
a real hero who does stuff for everybody
kids around the world
but about something i'm talking about
it's a gift but look at this is
for me from you and it's oh thank you
he's not priceless he's already watched
right now all right have to bear it
there's gonna be one of those oh yeah
boy am i glad i this is going to be hey
that's all right it's going to be a
keeper i told you the wrong side
no that's all right it's all right it's
great i should have i got another one
the right size but that was just a gift
like
ah i should have said cabezon no i don't
well that was just a more of a
gift all right thank you so that's
memorabilia
and then there's part one since that's
just this is our two part
this is a two-parter and the other was
i'm already kind of fixated
with this beer uh we got the let me know
about turn on this all right
so so because of uh your anniversary
today
oh that's not average it's [ __ ] wrong
i'm all cuz i'm i
have my whole swing i think i took the
right one got to pull out the shoes this
is uh
the new you know when dick van dyke when
he used to fall
and sometimes oh yeah yeah yeah you made
it around
look at that yeah in the shower
the same guy skip from atlanta drew you
a
oh man and there they are
thank you one dude that don't leave the
house and the other one the wife got by
the [ __ ] shorthand
together
[ __ ] hey man hey you've been a great
i mean just
you just brought a whole other energy to
this whole thing this is uh
now when someone goes missing i got
[ __ ] somebody to talk to it that
[ __ ] guy right here
i think it was hot i like it huh hey
life has been good to me
it's fun man it's awesome it's been fun
the podcast people
people love it
he said i met him when i was 11 well
that neverland ranch
i mean are we interviewing that is the
poll quote for the episode that's the
one right at the very top
oh man you can't you know even something
so innocent
you can't probably say anymore yeah
how'd you guys meet uh you know i was
six when i met george hold on
[Laughter]
you know what i mean you can't oh yeah
and also
speaking of uh you know because i don't
talk to my i don't talk to any of my
neighbors
you know that bad thing the first time i
moved
when i moved the first time i moved in i
moved the first time i moved in
i cut the trees because i hadn't been
cut in forever and then the neighbor
called and said hey you know i'm unhappy
that you cut these trees you know
they're on my yard and then he started
to debate me about you know his privacy
and all that [ __ ] and
that was probably the first week i was
in the house and i don't think that guy
he moved he moved within the last six
months but
where the house is kind of far even to
just have a neighbor
me and that dude were never going to be
cool because i said hey man
you need to go home man because you know
what are the disputes some are now dead
now deadly now because yeah instagram
everybody's filming everything that one
time over there i think in buffalo where
the dude shot there's a man in this
woman and his husband or wife and then
they they got into it the dude went to
the house and came back and started
shooting and they went back and
got another gun i mean you can't oh
this was like a recent video like the
past couple i remember seeing that that
was insane
yeah i was watching carson's dispute
with neighbors you know
dawn better look away just you know i i
told somebody
and i was thinking about it because i've
been asked a lot you know a lot of
questions on this
put you on neighbor next door does
anybody know where i could sell this
corn at a farmers market and then
citizen i'm here
go ahead go ahead and then some of these
people are just playing nasty
you know ramirez fans hey you should be
dead not him and yeah they go on
and so i get a lot of questions hey does
it bother you that all these people are
talking this
and i just tell them no i just ignore it
you know because if if you answer them
or give them a response
then they won you know if you ignore it
if somebody gives you the finger and you
see it you get pissed off
the guy who gave me the finger he won
right he got a reaction out of you and
that's what they're looking for
if you just ignore it like he didn't see
it well then
he loses he's pissed off because he
doesn't notice it completely
dude did you learn that at the academy
or is that uh social
from your last six months of social
media no no i just learned that in life
because in life right nobody taught me
that in the academy
and what did i teach in the academy
about anything about like um
mind stuff you know jedi mind
mind control how do you steal yourself i
wonder
you know what i say like hypothetical
like only latinos answer hypothetical
questions you know the cop comes and it
goes do you know anybody that would uh
want to see her disappear george do you
know anybody that would want to see her
disappear
the [ __ ] you're asking me for it i don't
know that's a hypothetical question no
but he is asking did
anybody that would be better off in life
if she wasn't here
no they didn't teach you they just said
be prepared for people yelling at you
they used to get in your face all the
time
they're all [ __ ] lying yeah they they
try to get reaction and your job just to
shut them out so you go along and try
and
uh get by without getting in trouble
because you you are human you know
eventually
you get pissed off enough is enough do
they teach you like body language and
all that stuff like they're
completely right in somebody's face and
somebody's and how they
they they dry mouth to those guys
looks up into the right it's a lie up in
the water yeah exactly you know i used
to keep
i've taught all all over the u.s on
interviews interrogations
and there is that body language up and
to the left up and to the right you know
are they are they thinking are they
lying are they right-handed are they
left-handed
you know are they they have darting
averting eyes you know do they big gulp
you know dry lips you know richard
ramirez
use a fingertip he did that and if he
and if you took his anxiety level up
his fingers would start going faster so
you just learn
uh those are you once you're more bad
they call those kinesis indicative of
deception
when you're lying piece of [ __ ] these
things come up and you can't control
them
he probably didn't even know he was
doing that no he didn't
yeah like i'm a foot tapper like i i
give it away real quick i'm like dad
put tappers the honors
just giving them time to make up an
excuse a lie you know some people you
know
you ask people you know what's first
thing when i talk about your grandmother
what's first thing comes up
what what your first thing about my head
yeah
her her okay retorts to me
i wanna be a comedian why i want people
to laugh let me go get your
[ __ ] first grade pictures so i could
tell if i wanted to interview you and
you were a suspect or something
or you were a witness you're an audio
person you hear
that's right you hear things i am audio
person
if somebody comes up what about your
what about your grandma what do you
think
oh she was so sweet she was kind always
baking for us making us go
there's somebody that's kinesthetic you
know hard you know right in here there
and if they said she was a beautiful
lady
they're visual so you try to figure out
what people are and then you play with
their anxiety level
up or down or if you're they're
witnesses you know you
leave the questions towards what their
strong points are there's one i didn't
know
i didn't know by the answer that you
could tell whether visual or
audio or yeah just a couple of questions
because of what i said
the way she okay and somebody said no
that's super cool i've never heard
anything like that i like
i started thinking of my grandma and
like i just went to facts right like
lives on a farm lives in nebraska been
in the same house for yana donna
see and all this time you thought i was
going to run overweight
when i was 15. silence at the level in
the farm
[Laughter]
octavia nebraska hey this is a good day
yes
that's cool awesome and i got another
one for when you go soloy
we do we have that that one isolated we
can we can give you the file when you
get your own podcast because you know
they'll be calling
your soy crime or something like that
reserve
your soy crime.com uh
you'll get your you'll get your full
engulfing you ever got the picture from
that guy yet
no he said he said he said he said well
he what he did he was probably walking
it across the u.s he wanted it he wanted
to finish another one
not not a painting just a drawing and
it's not even a i mean it's not a
it's not like someone somebody's you
know the mona lisa is like as big as
that
yes tiny but much smaller than you
expect it to be yeah
this guy uh okay leonardo da vinci man
like is that who did that
yeah it was da vinci you know those
dudes didn't live they looked like they
were 75 man when they were 40.
and it said it took him 35 years to do
that how can you [ __ ] start at five
all right get in there yeah like choose
him in a way he'd do that [ __ ] all day
long and just revising and doing
other projects it's crazy there was one
that there was one that he said that he
was working on there's one in
rome florence or somebody that
it started to talk to them you know
because i guess they used drugs back
then like
oh yeah they found it like in the paint
even too they'd be like
there's the picture it was a black and
white picture of my dad
and myself as a kid oh wow and he wanted
to do
when he did the painting he says hey by
the way oh i did another one
just with the pencil
he said so i'm saying it at the same
time this guy's a talented artist that's
great and he's the gentleman you're
talking about in the last podcast who is
he listens to the podcast too
yeah i think he's a he's a daniel parks
and he's just he's just a
a big he appreciates your work exactly
that's all it was and he said he was
getting ready
to quit painting he just was gonna stop
give it up
and when he saw the reaction that we had
to
yeah the one he just said you've just
validated what i'm doing it keeps me
going so
isn't that yeah i hope so yeah yeah i
think so that's awesome and i hope
i hope when we do this
uh i hope he gets some validation back
there
where he's from you know you know i
don't think you know it's so funny man
like you know social media is
i mean i'm not sure you know i don't
know man at my age
if i wasn't doing what i was doing
whether i'd be at
whether even have a facebook account
because you know i was at the house
trying to learn how to play hot for
teacher 17 hours a day
i'm still in the beginning and um
i'm not sure if i would want to let
people know about me
if i wasn't doing this like in the
beginning i think in the beginning of
facebook they would say hey we're out to
dinner at uh
dave and busters they go and [ __ ] rob
your house man
because then you were telling people
that you weren't that you weren't home
yeah so people that post live or
whatever
with what they told us it's like don't
ever
post like where you're at make it be
like from
last week or some [ __ ] that they don't
know where you're at you know yeah
yeah you know that's because i'm i'm i
try to be conscious
i don't post anything on on facebook but
i got to watch my kids i got to tell
them hey
i don't want people knowing why i'm over
here you know i'm not you know i'm
not a real prankster but i'm just going
to i was trying to do something and
i could i was trying to get a pair of
those avia uh
shoes and put them outside your window
so as we're getting back to normal and
people are starting to meet in person
again
or not in person but after the year
we've all had
i think anything that resembles anything
normal is gonna take time so
here's what's happening if you're
overwhelmed at all you're not alone it's
important to feel support from people
that you may know and not know support
doesn't have to be somebody that
that you particularly know an
encouraging word a gentle hand
uh we all talk about friends and
experiencing issues
with our friends but uh you know your
friends will not always give you the
advice
that you need all right because
uh you got to get on bias feedback if
somebody knows you what are they going
to tell you man
to get your life together they're going
to be like oh you guys will be fine you
live it in your car
uh a licensed professional and somebody
i mean
this is the age we're living in that uh
you can find somebody on top space
online and
actually you know you can get better
when you're at a low point
you think you're alone you're not alone
me and gil are right there
right there two honks and bucket will
come out
refreshed and ready and uh you know we
all need help sometimes and asking for
support
is i think really tough i'm not you know
gail i'm not sure i can say this
honestly
i would rather starve than ask somebody
forever
just because nobody ever made it [ __ ]
comfortable to ask anybody for
help man if you said hey man can i you
know you think i could what
if you make [ __ ] everybody can hear
you i think you know if i could stay
what do you have nowhere to stay
man that stuff was all batting until now
uh talk space offers individual and
couples therapy because
what's better than going in there by
yourself it's going in there with a
loved one
okay in addition uh to medication
prescribed reviews a lot of time people
get prescribed medicine that
it's not always the best for them uh
talk space will
work around your schedule and they're at
your convenience
i'm not sure you know i ordered stuff
online from like
vista mart you know they ordered
groceries but i think
talk space right here i thought that
they can deliver wellness is better than
having
you know [ __ ] cupcakes okay
whether you experience depression like
girl right now
anxiety loss two for two talk space is
the number one online therapy platform
to get help and to sort you out with
whatever issue you have i'll take you
down
it's you know what i think the word
issue is even like misleading
it's very it's vague if someone says hey
man
you know i can't accept a compliment and
they tell you to go [ __ ] yourself you're
healed
so start feeling better with a single
message match with a licensed therapist
when you go to talkspace.com and get 100
off your first month
with the promo code oh my god hi all uh
capitals and that's 100 off when you use
oh my god hi
talkspace.com i've been in therapy for
20 years with the same guy
i would go to talk space as soon as i
could turn this phone on when gill takes
off
and that's 100 off when you visit the
code omg
hi talkspace.com oh my god
filler filled with candy so we turned a
bad thing into a good thing that's
hilarious
one one shoe chocolate or jelly bean
yeah his sons are like that so so he's
been gone since 2014
2013 2013. and then the people that
i don't know who thought he didn't serve
as much time at prison he died like
people were disappointed that he died
because they wanted him to be in prison
is that right
i'd say they wanted him they wanted him
sure they wanted him to suffer he took
the easy way out we didn't get to kill
him
you know they they wanted to kill you
twice if he's a devil worshiper and he
goes to hell that
was like it's not going welcome
to the [ __ ] hamptons hey i'm here i i
found out
how many how many fans he has today man
he's got a fan following that is that is
a killer you know
hey so if you put them on the poster and
i'll come with a save for the stage
the uh uh what's that number again 818
1843 three three
eighteen forty eight three eighteen
forty three
eighteen forty three eighteen forty
three [ __ ] dyslexic
there you go we're flashing it on the
screen right in the bottom and then okay
so if you're richard ramirez fan
or a fan let's see if you're a fan of
law enforcement
we talked about defend the police i
didn't know what that meant until last
week
if you're a fan of law enforcement call
us and tell us why
and if you're a ramirez fan or fans of
the devil
the dip the devil call and tell his wife
i think
yeah any any serial killer anybody
that's like you know uh yeah
any serial killer out there that uh
you know needs a good handle gill's up
there creating other real guilt cuddy
number two part two so so you know that
because i mean this guy's been gone
for eight years and he's got fans oh he
does i mean
some are very kind you know some say you
know i'm a richard ramirez fan but what
you did was very good thank you very
much for all you did
hey but can you tell me because i think
he's really handsome
would he still if you wouldn't have
caught him you think he'd be alive and
loving today you know others so sinister
hey you thought you know because i
blocked a few
people and and i block them if it looks
like
they're going to be nasty that way just
see every reporting
you can report people too like if you
take a screenshot of you
take a screenshot oh i didn't know that
see i told you this
you know what he's more concerned
looking at his increase in followers
than the minutia of having an account
yeah i just block him out and
this guy says don't you don't say here
for the state you're not going to get
rid of me
you know you should be dead instead of
him you're no good you locked him up you
got it
okay just block him that way i don't
have to deal with him that one was me
and then he came back and he says i told
you you thought you were going to get
rid of me came back with another name
you didn't get rid of me i'm still here
and i'll be here for the rest of you
and block it again you know and and i
don't care
i don't know the guy i don't know what
he's got to you know i i
what is that though i have i have no one
it's a psychology of of a hater
of what's what's the mind behind
somebody that
you know you'll be surprised if you look
at the [ __ ] time that they're hating
you
they're [ __ ] hating you at the best
time of the day when the sun's coming
the [ __ ] could be
who can be mad at [ __ ] sun rising
even if you're go you feel you're
happier
i used to drive home when the sun was
coming up and i was happier than if i
slept 10 hours
and the sun was coming up
these guys don't realize you know
they're not going to hurt me i've seen
more death
you know right in combat i've seen more
dead bodies out here
what they say you know it's not going to
bother me but is it is it meant
as a it's meant to be acknowledged yeah
i mean
and if you don't give them acknowledge
they give up
i hope have you experienced this as
comedian i've heard a lot of comics talk
about this george where it's like
people will tweet you people will like
write something to you that's like super
hateful
and as soon as you give them any amount
of attention they're like oh i'm so
sorry i didn't think you'd actually
respond i'm such a huge fan
it's just like it's like lashing out
it's this is the worst tweet i ever read
about to me
i i wish that i had a time machine
so i could go back to the day that you
were born
and before you were born get a hanger
and put it in your mom's vagina and kill
you
before you were ever born
bad sweet and i was like [ __ ]
i was like wow man i mean
and i'll tell you right now that guy is
looking for a reaction
here whatever your reaction is 818 533
1843 because you know and there's a big
thoma behind it
hashtag hey so but that's all it is
if you were in school and to be like i'm
not touching you and they're doing all
that [ __ ] sure it's just on another
but if somebody you know 4 30 in the
morning 5 o'clock in the morning
whatever
that somebody's taking time out of the
beginning of the
best buck it's a gift to wake up and
pull that [ __ ] like
no consequences you're on the internet
you're totally anonymous i mean maybe
the person who
tweeted this to you they were just like
an egg profile or maybe it was their
actual profile but like
what's what's actually gonna happen to
this person probably nothing so what's
to stop them from being as
horrible as humanly possible to maybe
get a reaction from someone who they can
sure
and and the good part about it so far
but i mean you can't have a lot of them
though do
you know there's a lot of fans but
fortunately and i don't read because i'm
not up on this social media stuff
i'm getting instagrams from a lot of
people are saying
they've seen it and they're bad-mouthing
those people that are
saying [ __ ] about me so let them take it
on if you're because they're all reading
each other's
right yeah yeah so i i don't uh i read
mine i'm lucky i get to do that
well you know as a fan of of
i think if you were let's say we stick
to baseball if you were a baseball
player and you went to dodger stadium
and you saw
sandy koufax you would say oh my god man
there's
sandy koufax he was you know hall of
fame and one of the most amazing
pitchers ever or if you went
and saw kareem goes to baseball games or
if you saw magics at the game
they don't have to be of that sport to
still be interesting to
people as fans right so you and i right
here
you know the thing came out in january
everybody's seen it double scene and
i've seen a few times
and there's a guy named dead bug like
this dude's on youtube and it's
i mean it's that bug it's
it's gory and it's factual because they
don't try to
you know something that he just tells
what really happened and maybe has a
picture there's like the star 80 girl
and then there's like
people who died in porn and there's
people that are like neighbors that
take people out and try to live a life
like that dude that especially those
neighbors that cut the trees down
oh yeah like that so it's just like a
youtuber who makes
is like just sort of like these like
more
and he [ __ ] with everybody he'll say
there was a you know there's a lady
laying there he's like well you know i'm
going to say it right now is probably
not my type you know just like
90 years old and then uh they showed
everybody and the only people he didn't
make fun of
was you and frank he didn't say anything
about you in france he'd
go yeah look at this guy like he [ __ ]
with everybody
and they showed you your video like hey
this is what we're looking for all
of stuff there's a man out there
take a look over here oh those are the
videos they did in the in
the sheriff yeah really it was brilliant
it was the you know the [ __ ]
you know lady invented hand sanitizer
we're going to have a latino
too busy making vhs copyright that was
before the internet yeah
they said you're like made 25 they had
to send it to every every station right
now
and we did that because i said hey we
got to do something let me i'll do a
video
because i i just happened to be at one
of the stations and i listened to some
sergeant doing a briefing
and he was full of [ __ ] he didn't know
what he was talking about and i'm saying
if
we got 25 stations out there
and everybody's giving different
opinions you know doing
no good why not let's make a video let's
get it out
everybody gets the same information so
that's what we did we did two of them
and no need for a third one he got gone
yeah and there's people that are upset
listen if you're a criminal you get
caught there's a lot of criminals that
haven't
been caught so it's like you know hey
you you know [ __ ] you you caught him
there's still a lot of you know you
think he would be killing no he wasn't
gonna last that long
he i knew we'd catch him and he was
getting tired
yeah he said he was getting tired
it's always a matter of time right you
get complacent you make mistakes i feel
like and he knew he won't i've heard
he knew that it was only a matter of
time before we got him yeah he was
getting tired he knew it was a matter of
time before we got him
either either we'd get lucky or he'd
screw up
yeah and he did what it yeah he both
he did both when he got back i can't i
can't imagine
there's two things i can't imagine that
the way how high you jumped when the
phone rang behind you
in the middle of the night when you
thought somebody was in the house oh
i i think netflix
3 30 in the morning it's good to shut up
you're by yourself the family's moved
away just for safety and then you're in
there walking it i think you said
when you're back to every wall which is
the right the right way to do it sure
so it's the middle of the night
you think you hear something you might
see something you know i mean he's
around that area
sure and then the [ __ ] out of silence
the phone rings you probably went
bread oh it's good to be jesus out of me
it's good [ __ ] i mean i was
it i was i was i
it was tough and then they went
it scared me and they said call up uh
then linda arthur she was a very dear
friend of mine worked on our crime lab
she was a cop
and she says hey lady across street we
just got raped i think it's something
you're working on
because she had been out summer at crime
scenes so i
went down her house and it was sophie
was a uh victim
incredible and being conscientious
when i woke up i looked at the clock
whenever this is going on i'm looking
it's 3 30 in the morning and i'm saying
to myself goddammit what's he doing
right now
this guy's driving me nuts she'll
testify
because she was a nurse she also like
cops
kept track of time she says i looked at
the clock and it was 3 30 in the morning
when he was starting to sodomize me
that's spooky damn and so it was uh
it was good i used to look at the clock
when i was with women and i would be
like
it's like 11 52 i just twelve or two
draw
one just almost just make it to like a
new
day like i said i did it all day
nine minutes okay what else grant what
do we have all right yeah so uh we're
excited we're gonna do a segment we
haven't done
in a minute and with you at all gail
called it's actually had a couple names
actual news right we basically we find
funny weird news stories police to be
involved in some capacity
we just read them and sort of get would
you call it actual news
i mean because we're surprised that this
[ __ ] is real okay uh this is called
actual
this this is actual movie that's
actually the crusher
that's the signature right there 22.
that that was not to wear that's just
two
no that's what my wall so i have a i
have a a bat
signed by autograph by andre eather
oh yeah a friend of mine uh met him
there at the uh
dodgers stadium he's seen television he
got off he was an interesting dude man
uh andre yeah nice half french and half
latino [ __ ] i don't know he's from
arizona
he's a good guy i think he's yeah he's
just arizona he never really came off as
a
no nice guy the uh the guy that worked
there took me on a little private tour
jerry
turner who at that time was the uh he
was in charge of the visitors
uh dugout he made sure that all the
equipment and the food everything
they would take care of uh he's been
with him i think something like 43 years
he's got three world series rings and
a couple of pennant rings he's now in
charge of the
umpires room and shout out to jerry
jerry says hey would you
let me give you a tour i said if i could
take my grandson i might no [ __ ]
jerry
and he knows everybody there i said if i
can take my grandson with me he says
let's do it he said okay bring him down
he took me down he said okay where do
you want to start i said hey it's your
tour
where do you want to start he says you
want to meet vince gully
and i said holy [ __ ] yes yeah that's
better than the pope brother oh yeah
and so it went up introduced me took me
up to the press box
meet vince gulley the guy he was doing a
video
you know one of these commercials and uh
hey jerry you got a minute i got a
couple of friends here that wanted me
sure bring them in
and when we were done and and vin was so
damn just so accommodating so
nice genuinely nice and when we're done
one of the video guys says hey jerry
anytime you feel like internet
uh interfering with another commercial
we're doing he says come on back any
time
and they started laughing and vin scully
just said jerry
anytime you want to come back you know
you're welcome
and he says thank you van we walked out
we get out manny mona stops hey jerry i
need a favor
okay manny hey this is gil carrillo as
soon as i'm done with gil i'm giving him
a tour i'll come back and check up on
you
we end up down in the locker room he
takes me around there is uh
kershaw uh the guy that we got rid of
from cuba
uh gonna say i'm a twig yep kweig was
sitting there in his bbd this guy's
chiseled man
chiseled he was chiseled uh gonzalez is
sitting there with earphones on his feet
up just relaxing before the game
takes over there's andre ether he says
andre skill crew hey i've heard all
about you hey pleasure to meet you
hey come with me took us into some where
all the bats are imaginary
locker oh yeah equipped manager yeah and
so he took me in there took out a bat
for myself
one for my grandson autographed him took
pictures with us
uh just a great great man that's pretty
good he was at the ball game the other
day they got him on an interview
he was visiting the nice guy we got him
so this will be treasured and this will
go up on my wall good all right there's
a lot more where that came from
that's great i don't know i don't think
i think i have a little bit
i tried it forever in the beginning
didn't i never talk that much this is a
podcast baby it's all about time
uh i can jump right into the articles if
you guys want jump uh all right jim so
uh this one from the insider.com uh so
14 years after a sexual assault in tampa
a man has been charged with rape because
he entered his own dna
into a genealogy database think like a
23 in me sort of thing
here's the article all right police
detectives in tampa bay said they've
arrested a suspect in a 14 year old rape
case after using the database of
genealogy testing website to match
dna evidence the victim can now have
some closure in life said the assistant
tampa police chief ruben delgado
according to police reports took place
back in 2007 at the university of tampa
victim told detectives she was
intoxicated may have been stumbling
around with the suspect who they now
know to be jared vaughn
offered to walk her to her dorm room
where he proceeded to commit the crime
dna evidence was collected at the time
but didn't find any matches until 2020
when they revisited the case and now
included stuff like ged match and family
tree
which are just ancestry ancestry
websites i thought they couldn't
share that information there's another
that they're looking out for i don't i
thought they couldn't share the
information unless you
i don't know maybe that's how they do
the the the guy that was killing the
girls here
the golden state killed golden state
killer
the local one though
the black guy that was doing it right
here got a bunch of they
they did the familiar dna like that
and that's they ended up getting it from
a website they ended up who's that
uh you know do you know
the grammar sleepers oh yeah the grip
aaron aaron getting all the answers man
aaron
don't go to his pocket you'll see all
this
all the [ __ ] are missing all right
that's how they did it all right so so
all right listen everybody i guess you
better you know don't think that they're
not watching anyways if you're talking
about barbecue stuff or the fourth of
july or whatever
yeah you're [ __ ] two minutes later
you'll get a [ __ ] text from
sprouts telling you what they got for
the don't assume anything is private
nothing is private these days yeah yeah
right nothing is private that's right
is it against the law to eavesdrop on
somebody
or you have to let them know you're
there i don't know you have to you can't
say
let's say you go by a window you're two
people talking you have to say hello i'm
sheriff no as long as you're
real as long as you're in public they're
they're doing it you're in public
property no
okay but the eavesdrop on any phone
calls or anything like that then it
takes a court order
and some as in some states have like a
one-party consent versus two-party
consent where it's like
maybe i can take my side of a phone call
without asking but in other states
you have to have both i don't know what
it is i don't know it's like more of a
civilian thing i don't know about other
states i just know about here
yeah if we're going to do it without a
search warrant they got to know that
you're recording
yeah that's why when you call up all
these places you know doctor's office
in the area they hate this message maybe
exactly
so if you go through somebody's car and
you find something without a search
warrant
and it's admitted as evidence since you
didn't have a search warrant would they
throw that case out
it depends what you were searching for
at the time and whether it's relevant if
you're looking for
dope and when there's dope you find a
gun well that gun is still admissible
because you were in search of dope
if you find a tape and there's writing
on it with your
your murder victim's name on it well
then what you gotta do is you gotta you
confiscate it
but then you write a warrant to get the
contents of the tape
ah you just you can't watch until you're
done no
wow man that's crazy it's called
pre-search warrant search
pre-search warrants that's what some
people would say
yeah you got to write a search warrant
you know what you got to tell us the
truth because
people will be out there going that's a
pre-search war
that's our taser
yeah all those you know you don't you
don't know about about those things but
you know how about this how about when
you guys are sitting in what car kind of
car was it like a matador
a police car in a black and white or in
a no in a
yeah there were matador cars before and
then we went to chevy chevy caprices and
they went to port crown vix
but at the beginning those were all they
were all american that was
the first first lapd
car what was that a that was like a a
ford or a dodge or some [ __ ]
sure i don't know depending on what year
it was they went to we did chevy's for
one was the crime
in the mid 70s we were even using chevy
nova's and patrol and they used them for
dick parker
that's right so that's right so you know
i had a friend of mine that i said that
uh was alleged to have committed this
crime and then you know he walks out
we walk him out and he looks around he
goes look at all these cops out here
and me i don't [ __ ] see anything
i'm in junior we're the same age he's up
for murder
and i'm just walking by to say hello and
and i was like i don't see any [ __ ]
cars and
then when we drove away there was
probably all those matadors and
an anova and dudes out there you know i
remember for years they used uh plymouth
furies
yeah because you'd hear them going
[Music]
they make a lot of noise they didn't
move that fast but they made an awful
lot of them
they still like plymouth i don't think
it feels like the opposite of everything
you'd want in a cop car
yeah well yeah tell me if you ever
encountered this in your
way so how do they catch it with with us
grandma all right that's uh that's not a
medical field
through so through the database he
submitted his uh info it was
i don't think they're allowed to say
which one he submitted it through but uh
they were able to just track the dna
because they would reopen the case it
was a publicly
or i don't know if it was publicly
accessible or they subpoenaed it or
something like that
knowing that would you would you would
you apply would you do a test and send
your
dna in there oh hell no no i think that
that's really
ultimately that's not that i'm afraid of
anything but
it's i don't want it involved in
anything there's no need yeah well i
told you they already have everything
i've ever put on social media i'm
cleaner than safeway chicken i don't
care
my crime on my business uh all right so
uh
if you ever came across anything like
this police break up exorcism
at pennsylvania home depot so this comes
from pennlive.com
so police in lackawanna county
pennsylvania broke up an exorcism in the
lumber aisle of a home improvement store
on monday
details are scarce on exactly what was
going on inside the home depot but
police were called around 3 26 pm to
escort several people out of the store
for what was described as bad behavior
according to the reports
there was an exorcism held for trees
that had been turned into lumber
um the police blotter said uh the
facebook page gave a few clues as what
happened simply
uh what is that what news does that come
from that's [ __ ] that came from
your friends live dot com
uh the new york times of lackawanna
county i think is what it is
i've been praying for the trees to get
away from the people giving the exorcism
right and uh it didn't make sure that
hey that's just some [ __ ] you do at gosh
[ __ ] don't do that
don't do that at home but you do that
[ __ ] in lumber city true
hardware get that [ __ ] over there don't
bring it in here
uh they made sure to clarify it no
indication the incident had anything to
do with these
is every hot dog girl outside of home
depot fine i think that's one of the
rules
[Laughter]
nothing to do with the price of lumber
was the yeah to make sure because that's
maybe maybe yeah
it just sounds something like people
have too much time on their hands
there's people that have fetishes like
you know uh
you know boy exorcism
yeah this is not a journalistic
enterprise we do just pull some weird
we find weird headlines and we go from
there uh which is how we got this one so
this one from foxnews.com
very reputable depending on who you ask
uh 42 000 pounds of missing pistachios
leads to possible illegal pistachio
operation
uh okay very fun article at the top what
is that because because monsanto oh i
have a problem
how many times 42 000 pounds if i gave
you two pounds you give one back to me
so that is 21 tons that's
20. 21 tons of pistachios yeah they were
already picked
boxed everything in one in one ton sacks
they're 2 000 pound sacks the plan was
to move the pistachios into smaller bags
and resell them
uh your stamps okay you know that sad is
that it it's not
you know like every december when
somebody's trying to sneak a hundred
dozen of tamales in their luggage
and they get confiscated by customs and
those [ __ ] tamales get thrown out
like so many of the young youth of this
thing
uh you know and you can't go over there
and i was in chicago one time and i had
a couple cuban cigars and this guy's at
the bar and he's like
one of those cubans and i'm like yeah
and he goes how about this he takes out
this [ __ ] bag of women they're all
cohibas and all the roman juliet and i
go [ __ ] where'd you get those
i worked for customs
i went for customs and [ __ ] steals
them come on
they got all the things that the stuff
that custom takes away
breast milk and larry those are mine
uh cigars all that [ __ ] they take that
[ __ ]
home man oh yeah i'm [ __ ] you lose
your [ __ ] ipad you ain't getting that
[ __ ] back and if you get it back
you better look at the pictures that are
on it my dad loves to tell a story about
he was a kid and he
grew up in the bay area actually and uh
some cop he was like 18 years old he had
a handle of vodka or something in his
car cop found it for whatever reason
and he was just like all right i'll let
you guys off with the warning but i'm
gonna take this with me right here
and my dad was like all right you know
enjoy that on your time off guy wheeled
around came over gave him all tickets
for uh
minor intoxication
he couldn't help himself he had to say
something that's no good
you know this i told howard stern this
one so you know we're in washington dc
we just stay at like whatever the
holiday or some [ __ ] and on sunday
when you're done you're trying to get
something to eat pizza delivered to the
hotel
and uh we're in there we're smoking weed
we ordered pizza
and the a cop car just happened to
pull into the front of the holiday inn
and the lights were going at the same
time
that the pizza person knocked and i go
the cops because they thought they saw
that
and they took the [ __ ] weed and threw
it out of the balcony and it landed on
top of the cop car
oh oh my goodness are you going down
there lights are on we're looking over
the side and you can [ __ ] see the bag
you didn't even want the pizza anymore
we're all bad they had a good night that
[ __ ] was crazy throws it out it lands on
top of
unit 75. that's great all right so uh
another one here we have a classic tale
of corruption
uh this is from the clarion ledger which
is a mississippi-based uh outlet
that's where your artist is from
tennessee
so report representative stephen palazzo
spent campaign money to fight
allegations that he misspent campaign
money
uh republican mississippi rep palazzo is
using can
pay money to pay lawyers defending him
in an investigation into whether he
misspent campaign funds
uh palazzo who represents most of
southern mississippi paid jackson law
firm watkins and eager
more than 60 grand in december using
only campaign dollars according to
finance reports
they are listed as professional fees uh
justin brazell founder of a campaign uh
transparency group in jackson confirmed
that the payments were for legal defense
he offered no further comments on the
matter and uh palazzo's office
unsurprisingly did not return a request
for comments
of course man listen you don't you know
you're not gonna spend
your own money you're to spend whatever
you're stealing or taking from the side
that's what i say right and it looks
like he used that all that 60 grand to
come
in mississippi yeah 20 grand he spent
renovating a house that he owned on some
some riverfront
uh and proceeded to pay himself well did
you expect the attorneys to come to a
run-down house
you know the guy that was uh my drummer
and my talk show band
robert dimaggio of the dimaggio family
and you know
beard and i still talk so he he had a
charity that he was running
and like donating money to kids and he
used some of that money to
fund his own life and i think he got
like
five years or something like that he'll
be [ __ ] drumming every night and then
on the skins on the skins
hit that foot pedal man listen man i
don't think i could i told you if i was
a prisoner i'm blowing everybody up
yeah we'll do one more here uh this one
from actually fairly recently how much
time are you trying to kill are we close
to it no i'm vamping oh well when your
voice mails after this a little bit
yeah yeah yeah yeah do two hours or one
hour uh there's gonna be a two-parter
so we're gonna hit a little bit above
yeah uh have you been here for
voicemails at all no
we'll take what's the number george i
don't know what the [ __ ] it's right
there
eight one eight no i covered it eight
one eight five three three eighteen
forty three
leave us voicemails ask questions for
george and and gil
five three three one eight four three on
your radio dial thank you hey how far do
you remember about you remember how far
do you remember the day of stuff like
the day you first played little eager
no don't say no unless it was important
may 5th uh
no no i i don't remember that but but i
remember i was in third grade
when i kissed my first girl i remember
that
and i ran into her during school at one
of those assemblies at night she was in
school
and uh ran into her lately
and and she knows my wife knows her my
wife knows the whole family you know i
knew the brothers
and and i said uh
within the last six months i said you
know i still remember that first
you're the first girl i ever kissed with
your wife right there well yeah my
that's what i i didn't think and
my wife said i can't believe you really
said that you know she wouldn't say
anything then
she wrote it later that's almost like a
thumb remember like i would say let me
put a thumbtack right here for later on
without
nails that was in the third grade i
didn't think anything
[ __ ] third grade what year was that
that changed [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] 25 no like in the 50s
i was in the 50s so that's a long time
third grade
i didn't know i didn't even know what in
the i thought an erection was something
you built with an erector center
i didn't know anything about it i just
remember she was first girl and we
remained friends we graduated together
her brothers
uh one went to lapd one went to the fbi
we were just friends i don't see her
that often you know
years it's like hey man you don't have
to tell yourself you have to tell me
but i think it was a wrong woman out
there in the same game it was a wrong
move i tell you that
it is right i don't think it doesn't
matter what [ __ ] how how much time
you're in the third grade you're
probably [ __ ] 10 years old you're
like
oh it's a fun man
and then they're the ones in spanx
there's another [ __ ] tank a tagger
yeah that's good that's great uh all
right well
one more right uh so u.s olympian shelby
houlihan blames burrito for
positive drug tests listen so i hadn't
actually heard about this one until i i
printed the article
and it was pork i think what was that up
let's see uh when she blames on a pork
burrito that she bought from a food
truck
she tested positive for nandrolone a
banned steroid
after submitting for like a typical drug
test uh she competed in the 2016 summer
games 5 000 meter 1500 meter races
uh qualified for us olympic trials uh
but the band will effectively bar her
from the
2020 olympic games in tokyo that are
obviously okay
not as a fan but let's say it wasn't
sport and you heard
the details of that what do you think of
that i'd be screaming be uh
there there was a wanking gesture there
you ate it
you did it there's got to be another
reason look at nobody's ever
i've i've tested for drugs and i even
read those all the time
look at me look at this tabernacle it
didn't get like this
you know no no but but that you know i
guess it's a viable
i mean you know boxers probably had had
to start that
thing with it so just your your opinion
as a
law enforcement in my my opinion just as
an everyday citizen
you know i i don't buy that she got it
from a burrito
how does she know she got it from a
burrito
how does she know it came from that
is the uh thank you very much and that
is why
gil carrillo real carrillo wants to be
your sheriff if you're out there in the
united states
and you like a week with guilt he'll be
the sheriff of your
of your county and then take pictures
that he'll talk about his reminiscence
it's like that moment at the end of a
murder mystery where they're like tell
cheryl i'm sorry they're like
i never said it was cheryl
that's right that's great and even here
at the end of the article it says you
know what that's a great point isn't it
it's the burrito you wouldn't know how
about the [ __ ] did you know it was
the bird
and it says other cases like this the
sort of party line is
it ends up being an athlete's personal
duty to ensure that no prohibited
substance enters his or her body
regardless
you know by burrito or by other sort of
choice i don't think there's anything
could have been a hamburger if she had
choreo she would have
ran faster yeah which
at my age that's it uh well you want
some voicemails so
drop pop on the cans if you guys we got
the headphones right here
all right you want another one i think
we need another one i'm gonna grab you
guys another beer or something tag
what's that got more out there already
how long did i talk in the beginning for
an hour uh no we haven't been on for an
hour
how those gummies hitting dude oh man
with the beer
awesome it's good hey what's that
picture going to show up anywhere we got
to wait till the next podcast
i'm sending it to the retro mirror fans
[Laughter]
no we'll send you that we'll send it to
you yeah we can send you that art we can
put it out there
stuff like that that's great yeah he did
a good job huh
the guy skipped yeah yeah skip i met uh
i think skip
drew dl on instagram and there's a
there's a thing where
where instagram works like if you see
somebody that's an artist and all of a
sudden you're like you know hey i like
the way they draw the
you know and they'll send you a thing or
whatever
probably good for business not good for
yeah so i'm trying to look them up right
now not good
if you expect to be liked by everybody
like a lot of people
i think a lot of people oh yeah oh yeah
let's think i'm beeping here
uh okay you guys right here some some
voicemails let's hear it
and then my daughter left me a voicemail
and we'll hear that one at the end
because i think this one
because she was looking on me i'm
[ __ ] tick-tock so i put something up
there
oh really i wasn't i haven't pulled that
one we'll see you guys if our deal is in
jeopardy
all right so love advice everything no
particular order here we go
hey oh my god hi podcast uh i'm a huge
fan of george lopez
i've been a huge fan since uh oh my god
since i could watch tv
um my dad was a huge fan of and
ever since then i just haven't stopped
watching his shows
um i mean your show i have a question uh
the question i
do have is i'm 25 years old and i
am attracted to this 40 year old guy
that i live next to
and um my friends are
accusing me of having dad issues uh i
have my dad
i just steal a certain half away for
this guy
and should i pursue anything or should i
just put these feelings away
i think that is a very good question you
know that i think that's
a situation gil thank god you're here
the man handler
the uh the squash last week
bug squasher beef sports foreign
question um so what do you think 25 year
old in love with a 40 year old you know
what
potential that first of all that's
really i don't think it
that big an age difference uh to make
even a situation where for 15 years
i mean if i were your dad i'd be seeing
me find somebody else a little closer to
you
but i'm not your dad 15 years isn't that
much
you know so so long as he's a
he's healthy he's good and a good dude
well you know here's i'm not
i don't think i've ever said this when i
was uh
in the early 70s my mom remarried a guy
that was like 45 years
older than she was and it
that's the significance i couldn't i
couldn't i'm like the [ __ ] dude
should be dead
why are you [ __ ] spending time with
him he could be here with me
but you know it was uh and he was you
know he was in shape good dude i mean
i think he even still had his [ __ ]
baby imagine [ __ ] being 85 with your
[ __ ] baby teeth
and uh every time we went somewhere man
they weren't baby teeth he's just older
right there on the [ __ ] way out so
every time he went somewhere man like i
was
even at that age i was like man this is
this you're just trying to scare him
and did my mom have dad issues i think
yeah
and then you know i have him because he
wasn't around
no but i mean doesn't every
person have that issue doesn't yeah come
on
what that makes any kid feel like like
he's meant to be there
[Laughter]
all right so so headline i mean you guys
pretty much appreciate when did that
happen it's not terrible when did that
happen
when you said that was my first
girlfriend was that years ago or just
no no it was just uh we went to a
funeral within the last six months
oh my god all right right after they
were easing up on coven because we had
to go to the restaurant it was outdoors
we got to take our mass off while we
were eating it in years you made it
is that that's really maybe the worst
thing you well yeah if i could take
anything back that would have been the
one that i'm thinking but
that's the worst dude you're my hero oh
man
it's i yeah
and nobody said i was perfect well you
know it's not what you meant you know
it's the thing you know it's like
we're not on that thing i don't know
what you're looking at on the screen
i don't think you'll see this but but
you know what i mean it's like
you're such a we're all good dude if
you're telling the truth it's like
like well i went to the ice house one
time when i went back when i was living
with ann and i said
oh i saw my first girlfriend or some
the first girl ever told you know
do you do any no
question uh you know listen i could get
anybody else in here
um but but uh i said that you know
unbeknownst to me that it would become a
[ __ ] thing forever
yeah and it's nothing it's nothing it
was said
in innocence i didn't mean anything no
never
i i haven't uh seen the ladies since
uh it just and and
it hasn't been brought up again but now
that i've talked about it here no we'll
cut it out and we'll put
we'll save it for the christmas reel
for the [ __ ] end of the year
i haven't thought about her in hours all
right what else
oh so what was the answer to that girl i
mean so it sounded like you guys were
pretty much
down forward i didn't care do you a
little dude make sure he's not a
murderer
you know i i don't i don't really mess
around with it with
with any women anymore but when i did
that one time we were eating and this
girl was considerably younger i think it
was
more than 15 years and then uh when i
was coming out of the bathroom i ran
you know into the waitress and she said
your daughter asked for that dessert
i gave it to her i hope that's okay i
said oh yeah yeah that's fine
that's what she said didn't even you
know maybe maybe
i think they knew they're if they're
talking about was it in
hollywood was it elsewhere because i
feel like out here that people know they
don't do that
you don't take that chance northwest you
know and then and this girl who knows
you know this girl may have the legs of
a 26 year old son yeah all right we got
uh we got another one here some more
advice
some more advice oh this is a good
opportunity to say like if you're gonna
leave a voicemail
like the shorter and the more quickly to
the question the better the easier it is
for
for us to pull and for the answer all
right there are unfortunate ones they're
like two minutes oh you're trying to
tell them how to leave
i'm just saying they're good questions
rules have to follow and leave me a
message uh all right next up
hey georges lopez this is zach from
austin texas again
yo man i got i got another i got i got
another question i gotta ask you goddamn
there's this white boy at my job right
he got dreadlocks and [ __ ]
man the other day my co-workers told me
that he wants to be my friend
how do i tell him i don't want to be his
friend but like not in a mean way
like i don't want to hurt his feelings
because i'm being like a liar
he likes me like that but i don't go
like that man
so what should i do how do i how do i
tell them
i don't want to be your friend but like
by not telling him i don't want to be
his friend tell him listen to george
lopez when he says
yeah is that what does that mean if
somebody says hey i want to be your
friend that you
that's a bad thing i don't know it
sounds like maybe this uh austin i think
was his name it sounded like he didn't
necessarily know
it was exactly he's from austin okay
there you go excellent
um i love it uh it sounds like he didn't
exactly know
what context this guy wanted to be his
friend but uh i mean
kind of from the white dreadlocks thing
he doesn't want it no matter what i
don't think a white drew i've never seen
a little potito out there with with
dreadlocks
that's exactly that'll be that'll be on
the reel to the game
so what do you think i mean good good
boundary drawing question maybe not for
this guy but in general it works
you don't want to be friends with
someone before you do well
what's the worst thing you i mean
you know there is gaydar so if they if
if one of them is
gaydar has gaydar you know what that is
you can tell gay radar it was before
grinder
um that you might be able to tell you
know
who plays in the american league who
plays that nationally
[Laughter]
nobody ever you know so simply who knows
who's the picture in the catcher
i've heard of pitchers and catchers
before
um i don't know man i i think you know
it's vague at best i think i think you
have the right to
friend anybody you want to whether he's
you know you're not gay you know i don't
care who it is it doesn't sound like
it's romantic
yeah it's up to you but with the way
that people feel about
just everybody being different you know
it's [ __ ] dangerous for anybody
manager
that's probably why it's a friend
they're probably like hey will you be my
friend at least you're like oh okay
you i'll be your friend have a beard if
they work together or whatever
but you know it's it's awful right now i
think just
it's a it's a tough it's a tough world
tough time man
and and all of this stuff in the last 14
months and you know
not you've seen all the businesses that
aren't around anymore it's horrible
you look at business and my daughter
who's an executive assistant
uh she was just telling me a little
while ago before i left
she's trying to get reservations
someplace in pasadena for
lunch for the executives from the disney
corporation
and she says dad everyone i'm going to
call
don't open for lunch anymore they won't
open till four o'clock
they're not many places opening up nice
places
yeah that are opening up because four
o'clock because of cobin when
because everything hit they're not
getting employees back yeah they don't
have the staffing
that's a big deal how much you think of
that is is uh
is real i could see you can really see
it but you know like
you watch the news and you go they're
gonna cancel you know thousands of
flights
uh in the summer and then you think okay
because a lot of people didn't come
didn't come back do you think that's
that do you think that's true like a lot
of people wouldn't
i've got to believe it is you know a
very dear friend of mine who's the owner
of steven steakhouse right there
in the city of commerce jim uh jimmy
philippine
i was with him last night and he's one
of the guys that had to close
he was open seven days a week eleven
o'clock through two in the morning
one of the biggest salsa places on the
weekends
in the county he's now open wednesday
through sunday
four o'clock until uh two and during the
week i think he closes at midnight
but he can't afford to open because he
can't get his employees back
they're saying hey we're making more
money being unemployed then we are
working yeah
that's the reason why not because they
found better gigs but [ __ ] they're
honest
[Music]
not working i got off the freeway right
here in burbank by the studios
and the restaurants right there big
signs everybody's asking for help
and they're not open you know they're
closed during the day but they're asking
for help they need people they need
to have man i never thought it like i
thought people were trying to look for
jobs i never thought
no just trying to [ __ ] live oh you
can get any kind of job you want right
now people are just
hey why do i go to work for 20
an hour when i can get with minimal out
i can get more money staying at home
doing nothing and even if you have kids
or somebody's watching your kid
that you don't have to pay for that is
that dog eating that the [ __ ] wires
little tape little tape situation
it's okay we have george's adorable dog
stitch in the
in the audience today stitch looking a
little hungry going for some tape
oh there's some food out there stay hang
on for another two hours yeah
we're almost there buddy what else oh
yeah no okay oh he wants that right
yeah you are are you a dog lover girl
yeah you know i i've always liked dogs
my wife never has uh yeah you know she's
she's not been a dog lover but
about three months ago now what do you
mean why she's married to one she don't
even bargain
we had a stray you know just running the
streets came up
and kind of befriended uh my house
the family and the guy look the dog
looks
sick and wild skinny dirty
and my neighbor and myself both called
animal control said hey we don't know
what this dog has you know maybe you can
come get it
so they came by and you could tell that
the dog had been mistreated
you couldn't get close to it and then
run away
so the dog pound finally said hey here's
a leash if you can get the leash on him
we'll come back pick him up
and i said all right they left you the
least yeah they left police here
animal half control so i told the wife i
said well i can't leave this dog out
here like this
got to feed him put some food let's get
some food and water
like little bread crumbs like hansel and
gretel so we put paper bowls out there
walks back into the house and he goes
every night and he was sleeping on my
patio every night
he'd go out during the day go take a
[ __ ] somewhere else but he wasn't my dog
so i didn't care yeah that's good
he kept coming back and i got him to the
point where i got him
finally coming up close to me eating out
of my hand wow
so that's pretty good that you know
that's the whole thing man i got a
meeting out of my hand and when i eat
out of my hand he rolled over and he
wanted me to rub his belly wow
crazy so i told the lady i'll be back i
gotta take my car for servicing when i
come back don't worry i'll call the
death squad
and she says what do you mean the death
squad i said well animal control
you don't want the dog they're going to
pick him up they're just going to go
kill him
and when i came back from service she
had a stainless steel water bowl a
stainless steel food bowl
and a bed for the dog to sleep in and i
said i guess we get to keep the dog
oh wow so we kept the dog got him
vaccinated got him this got him that had
operation done on the
[ __ ] and now the dog i don't know who
made out better the dog
with us or us with a dog wow
that's beautiful his name is milo and
milo comes he you know my wife gets
pissed off because
she cooks chicken for him you know when
we had to give him medication i said how
are we gonna get he doesn't like the dog
food we're giving him
[ __ ] and the doc said hey boil some
chicken
make some rice no seasoning cut it up
give it to and he eats it up
so she does that every day she takes him
out he goes and walks and takes care of
business but yet
all i got to do is say hey milo doc
comes up man
he's awesome how old is he they say he's
five years old oh he's still a little
mixed terrier
white lovable my wife loves him he's a
lap dog he comes over here
yeah right there with her she loves him
and the whole family loves him so i
don't know who's better in him we love
the dog
no i think that i think that that's true
you know i think that you know dogs
with people you know especially you know
they use them now and
you know i always use them in hospitals
and stuff and with inmates
but if you're alone you know like i'm
alone in the house with
with the dogs i've rescued probably 25
maybe
yeah and the reason that i did was
because of what you were talking about
is that
when lisa was in here from big love the
rescue
that sometimes they leave him at the
house then people move away
and the [ __ ] dog won't go anywhere
because he's like they're coming back
and then they get them and like that you
can't go in the air he'll bite you it
shows his teeth
and then they show him some kindness and
love and the dog comes
to you every time yeah he's just
uh he's a great dog that's the she's
[ __ ] it's
just going crazy maybe that's our key to
wrap this one up
got some sort of velcro situation oh
yeah all right
but uh okay hit the people with the
number tell them uh
what is it guilt the number is
uh [ __ ] i don't know it's upside down
there it is eight one eight five three
three one eight four three
call one call there you go will gill get
the
sign clayton kershaw shoes in the next
episode only that i haven't known
find out next time awesome i'm looking
to heaven
you